there is a big concern that automation
especially
powerful AI will get rid of jobs there
are people who lose jobs and as you were
saying the sense is
throughout history of the 20th century
automation did not do that ultimately
and so the question is will this time be
different
right that is the question will will
this time be different and it really has
to do with how quickly we can merge with
this type of intelligence
uh whether
Lambda or gpt3 is out there and maybe
it's overcome some of its you know key
problems
uh uh and we really have an enhanced
human intelligence
that might be a negative scenario
um
but I mean that's
that's why we create Technologies to
enhance ourselves
uh and I believe we will be enhanced
we're not just gonna sit here with
uh
uh 300 million uh
modules in our neocortex we're going to
be able to go beyond that
um
because that's useful but we can
multiply that by 10.
uh 100
000 a million
um
and you might think well what's the
point of doing that
it's like asking somebody that's never
heard music well
what's the value of music I mean you
can't appreciate it until you've created
it
there's some worry that there will be a
wealth disparity you know a Class A
wealth disparity only the rich people
will be
basically the rich people will first
have access to this kind of thing and
then because of this kind of thing
because the ability to merge will get
richer exponentially faster and I say
that's just like cell phones
I mean there's like four billion cell
phones in the world today
in fact when cell phones first came out
you had to be fairly wealthy they
weren't very inexpensive
she had to have some wealth in order to
afford them yeah there were these big
sexy headphones and they didn't work
very well they did almost nothing
so you can only afford these things if
you're wealthy
at a point where they really don't work
very well
so um so achieving scale is and making
it inexpensive is part of making the
thing work well exactly
so these are not totally cheap but
they're pretty pretty cheap yeah uh you
can get them for
a few hundred dollars
especially given the kind of things it
provides for you there's a lot of people
in the third world that
have very little but they have a
smartphone yeah absolutely and the same
would be true with AI I mean I see
homeless people have their own cell
phones and yeah so your sense is any
kind of advanced technology will take
the same trajectory
right It ultimately becomes cheap and
will be affordable
uh I probably would not be the first
person to
put
uh something in my brain to connect to
computers
um because I think it will have
limitations but once it's really
perfected
and at that point it'll be pretty
inexpensive I think it'll be pretty
affordable
so in in which other ways as you outline
your book is life getting better because
I think well I have I mean I have 50
charts in there yeah where everything is
getting better I think there's a kind of
cynicism about
um like if even if you look at extreme
poverty for example for example this is
actually a poll taken on Extreme poverty
and the people were asked
has poverty gotten better or worse and
the options are increased by 50
increased by 25 percent remain the same
decreased by 25 decreased by 50 if
you're watching this or listening to
this try to to try to vote for yourself
seventy percent thought it had gotten
worse and then that's the general
impression
88 thought it had gotten worse or
remained the same
only one percent thought it decreased by
50 and that is the answer it actually
decreased by 50 so only one percent of
people got the right optimistic estimate
of how poverty is right and and this is
the reality and it's true of almost
everything you look at you don't want to
go back 100 years or 50 years things
were quite miserable then but we tend
not to
remember that so literacy rate
increasing over the past few centuries
across all the different nations
nearly to 100 percent across many of the
nations in the world it's gone way up
average years of education have gone way
up life expectancy is also increasing
life expectancy was
48 in 1900
and it's over 80 now and it's going to
continue to go up particularly as we get
into more advanced stages of simulated
biology
for life expectancy these Trends are the
same for at Birth age 1 Age 5 age 10 so
it's not just the infant mortality and I
have 50 more graphs in the book about
all kinds of things
even spread of democracy which I
bring up some sort of controversial
issues it still has gone way up
well that one is uh it's gone way up but
that one is a bumpy road right exactly
and some somebody might represent
democracy and
and go backwards but
we basically had no democracies before
the creation of the United States which
was a little over two centuries ago
which is in the scale of human history
isn't that long